we've been doing some Paxman in some
chain rule let's have a go this is a
question okay so the first thing that I
do now
watch out here because we know that you
know 5 times 3 is the same as 3 times 5
multiplication is commutative you can
change the order no problems ok division
though division is not commutative non
commutator I was gonna say mutated but
that doesn't make sense
20 divided by 4 is very much not the
same as 40 divided by 4 divided by 20
okay so where is here
it didn't matter what was what here it
does matter it's in alphabetical order
so that's easy
you've got you on the top and B on the
bottom because that's how I started
things off right you want V so when
you're labeling things so you don't
confused them
it's enough for medical Waterson that's
easy
yeah that's true watch out first okay
I'm going to start just by quoting this
guy not because as you said no cuz
meritorious but just so that I know I
can put the my patience it
so the you - - UV - although Martin V
squared ok V just by itself that's x
squared plus 1 what's your - in this
case it's just one I'm gonna stick that
guy in I know it has a little effect but
that way I'm like okay I've done the
first one no I've done the second one so
I'm checking off in my head take away U
which is just X what's V - in this case
- X Reagan all over and then this guy at
the bottom gets squared now
traditionally we don't really muck
around with this guy okay you can see
one of the reasons why by the way you
know when we were solving like okay this
is a rational function this rational
function when you were graphing someone
it's in fact we graphed one just like
this earlier the denominator is
important but the numerator is kind of
more important than you've already gives
you
like roots and stuff like that so this
guy that denominator just leaving it
like that is generally no problem
especially when you get some really
ridiculous stuff down the bottom
generally it's quite to find a later
let's expand the top and then we can tie
this thing up x squared plus one minus
two x squared
yeah all over just gonna leave this guy
as he is I gave nothing out of
simplifying or expanding you much today
and so now I'm done tada suppose I could
factorize the top if I wanted to in the
future when you're trying to work out
where this numerator is equal to zero
it's clearly advantageous to factorize
that you may not make it one minus x one
process but here I just had the review
unfinished I think I think you're there
all right let's give it a shot see right
label them right okay when I
differentiate this I'm just gonna put
all my pieces together and then I'm
going to anyway okay so what have I got
on the top I've got help me out here
what's me X what's you - X take away
what's you x squared plus one B - one
okay all over x squared
there's my is my V my denominator okay
tidy me up on the top here okay what if
I got to Sally - x squared take - x
squared minus one
yep whatever x squared okay watch for
those brackets okay I can tidy up a
little further
x squared take one on the numerator and
I'm kind of finished though I'm gonna do
one more thing and then mix very
suspicious um this because on the
numerator I can break this apart to - do
you agree with that I could say that
that part there x squared on x squared
is just 1
and this guy is just a separate guy now
you're like ooh that's unseasonable
simple you're right it is because even
this is the question it's kind of a
question that not question let's come
back to this guy up here come back to
your first line and in fact it's not
just the dreary XK plus 1 over X it's
also the derivative of X plus one X
right
I just evaluated out the fraction yeah I
only have one term on the denardis so
even though it's written as a question
you don't have to write it as a question
so therefore you don't have to use the
quotient rule in fact using your powers
you could have just gone straight yeah
right so I put up this example because
just because it looks like a cushion
don't necessarily treat it like one
question really is actually something we
try to avoid on this V squared business
it's kind of gross it makes things out
of really messy if you could avoid it
do it like so now that you now that you
recognize it and you're actively looking
you're actively seeking to avoid the
quotient rule wherever you can look for
things always simplify first before
you're different you okay in just the
same way that if I gave you something
like
three times you could of course go ahead
and work out what 1024 times nine nine
years and 273 times 512 but of course it
would be smarter to say well this is a
common factor and then that's what we're
gonna take this oh wait I mean I think
that's me 243 sorry
so that would become 81 and then I
should have gone nine good night
no become 27 it's been 10 I think I'm
done yeah so in other words before you
make things worse by multiplying out or
by differentiating right simplify first
and then differentiate does that make
sense